and now
please welcome to the stage
secretary hillary rodham clinton
hello everybody
hello
thank you thank you isn't it wonderful
isn't it wonderful to be back here in
person with so many
friends and former colleagues and fellow
democrats from every corner of the state
well i am delighted to be here with our
terrific governor kathy hokel and our
lieutenant governor brian benjamin
they have brought
new leadership for our state and new
hope for our future
and here in this great city i want to
thank our new mayor eric adams for his
hands-on
energetic no-nonsense leadership
and thanks also to my friends and our
senators
uh chuck schumer and kirsten gillibrand
our entire congressional delegation
for fighting so hard for new york and
making progress despite the obstacles
and let's hear it for our attorney
general tish james our comptroller tom
dinapoli
speaker carl hasty and leader andrea
stewart cousins
state chair jay jacobs and everybody
who's working so hard to move new york
forward because my friends we need smart
effective principled leadership now more
than ever
not only in our state but also in our
country and the world
just think about it we have lost 65 000
new yorkers to the pandemic
that is a lot of grieving families and
broken hearts
and our economy as you know so well took
a real hit
with businesses closing jobs
disappearing
everything costing more than it used to
and yet we are now in the midst of a
robust recovery
and we still have work to do but we are
moving forward
but i want us to remember
that too many parents and caregivers had
to shoulder impossible burdens
how many of you had to be your
children's teachers
or your grandchildren's teachers
how many of you had to really deal with
the stresses that the pandemic caused
for so many of us
we've asked an awful lot of our children
and our teachers haven't we
we've asked a lot of our nurses and our
doctors
and our essential workers who kept our
stores open
kept the lights on
in fact we asked a lot of everyone on
the front lines who kept us safe and
healthy and working
and we have faced these challenges here
in new york
at a time when our nation is deeply
and dangerously divided
now it is one thing to have political
disagreements
those are natural and healthy
but it is an entirely different thing
all together
to lose a shared sense
of truth
facts and reality itself
and
i know many of us hoped that defeating
trump would start to heal our divisions
i certainly did
that maybe just maybe the madness would
break
but now it should be clear to all of us
that the struggle
for unity and democracy is far from over
when the republican party
officially embraces
violent insurrection as legitimate
political discourse
when storming the capital assaulting
police officers trying to overturn an
election
are being normalized
we are in uncharted territory
and make no mistake
our adversaries around the world are
watching
republicans are defending
coup plotters they're curbing voting
rights at precisely the moment
when democracy needs champions
when we should be standing together
against autocracies like russia and
china
january 6 last year was a gift to them
because they know something we need to
remember
america is only as strong as our unity
and our democracy allows us to be
that's why new york
must be not just the home of the statue
of liberty we must be the defenders of
liberty
not just a laboratory of democracy
but a protector of democracy
and we must reject the big lie about the
2020 election and the cover-up of the
insurrection of last january
6.
and we can't get distracted whether it's
by the latest culture war nonsense
or some new right-wing lie on fox or
facebook
by the way they've been coming after me
again lately in case you
might have noticed
it's funny the more trouble trump gets
into the wilder the charges and
conspiracy theories about me seem to get
so now his accountants
have fired him
and investigations draw closer to him
and right on cue the noise machine gets
turned up doesn't it
fox leads the charge with accusations
against me counting on their audience to
fall for it again
and as an aside they're getting awfully
close to actual malice in their attacks
but as i said don't get distracted
don't let the extremes of any or either
side throw us off course
focus on the solutions that matter to
voters not the slogans that only matter
on twitter
let's offer an alternative vision that
inspires and motivates
let's show
that democracy works
that it delivers results for people and
makes life better fairer and more
prosperous for everyone that's what joe
biden and kamala harris are trying to do
every single day
and it's what kathy hokel and brian
benjamin are trying to do right here in
new york
in fact it is
what democrats are running on in this
election year democrats are fighting for
safer communities and healthier families
with more opportunities for our kids and
schools that are both open and fully
funded
democrats are fighting for better jobs
and higher wages for everyone for health
care and housing that doesn't break the
bank
for making life affordable not just for
those at the top
democrats are fighting for cleaner air
to breathe and water to drink
for common sense that tells us vaccines
work and climate change is real
democrats are fighting for the rule of
law and for judges who follow it
for the right to vote the cornerstone of
our democracy for the right to organize
because we need unions now more than
ever for the right
for the right for women to make our own
health care decisions
now
all this and more is at stake in this
election isn't it
new york and the country has an
important choice to make because
republicans have a very
different
agenda
republicans will take tax cuts
like the child tax credit away from
hardworking families and give them to
billionaires
republicans will claim they're on the
side of parents and family values but
they will do nothing for actual parents
or families nothing on child care
nothing on paid leave nothing to help
working moms and dads get by and get
ahead
they will do nothing to invest in our
schools or make college more affordable
they'll ban books but do nothing about
guns
they'll make it harder for people to
vote but easier for big corporations to
bust unions they'll let polluters trash
our environment and let donald trump
trash our democracy
that's why i intend to work my heart out
to elect democrats up and down the
ticket this november
and that is why i am so happy to support
kathy hoco for a full term as governor
of new york
i've known kathy for a long time and i
can tell you something everybody is
learning no one will work harder for the
people of the empire state every county
every community she is a governor for
all of us
and by the way is it about time that the
state that gave birth to the women's
suffrage movement
the state that has always been at the
forefront of progress and reform isn't
it about time we elect a woman as our
governor
you know
it's been 22 years since i stood before
this convention
receiving your
votes to
endorse my candidacy for the senate
new york took a chance on me back then
and i'll never forget that now
now a lot has changed a lot has changed
since then
i don't want to blonder um
and new york and america have been
through a lot
we've all had our share of ups and downs
but
i've never lost my faith in our future
you know robert kennedy whose senate
seat i was so honored to hold
reminded us we are a great country
an unselfish country and a compassionate
country
if we choose to be if we fight to be if
we elect people who bring out the best
not the worst in us and despite all the
ugliness that we see too much of
i still believe
that
we can bring that decency to our
politics
hope to our communities defend our
democracy share broader prosperity
together
so please join me in welcoming the
governor of our great state kathy huncle
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a reason they call us the
democratic party we love to party right
oh and what a celebration this is what a
celebration of our values our party and
great leaders like hillary clinton
welcome back hillary clinton it is so
great to see you and to hear your voice
of reason
thank you for that introduction
and this since my very early days in
local government
i've been so inspired
by your strengths and your tenacity
and your belief in the power of
government to do good
you've always inspired me you and every
single elected woman who came before me
made historic moments like this
possible
and i thank each and every one of you
the heart and soul of the democratic
party for giving me the opportunity
to serve as the very first female
nominee for governor
[Applause]
[Music]
i accept your nomination
and i do so with a heart full of
gratitude and humility
and i will never ever take for granted
the trust you've placed in me and my
leadership
i also thank my family
for their enduring belief in me
and for their unconditional love
thank you thank you thank you everybody
[Applause]
i'm going to talk about my family let me
talk about my family i appreciate the
enthusiasm
friends
[Applause]
thank you thank you my friends thank you
thank you
democrats
it wouldn't be the same without a lot of
raucous
this is who we are
and i want to thank my family
for their enduring belief in me
and for their unconditional love
from my father
who's with us today
who first encouraged me to run for
elective office
and my mother patricia
whose empathy and compassion for those
who have blessed
shape the person i am
[Applause]
we're gonna get through this my friends
and i'm proud to acknowledge
dissent in our party
i'm also proud of receiving 85
of the vote in this room
thank you
thank you
thank you for that
so
as i was saying
all right
new york's
first first gentleman
my husband bill whose love and support
is highways
and our children will and katie and
their spouses christina and matt have
been bored my absences with nothing but
love
and in my five siblings
[Music]
with this special way of keeping me
humble
i love you at all
the jay taycom
what a leader
what a leader in a time where party
meets with jay jacobs
thank
you and to my brothers and sisters and
organized labor let's hear from all of
you
[Music]
yes we can and we will
it's all the advocates the grassroots
and faith leaders and many elected
officials are here today
in new york filled with optimism
and opportunity
thank you for sharing this moment with
me
i've been a democratic advocate activist
starting as a high school volunteer
working with buffalo's own tim russell
to help elect senator daniel patrick
moynihan
let me tell you my friends
it was a time of incredible cynicism
and distrust of governance
in the immediate years following
watergate
and the divisive vietnam war that picked
family members expanded
for one reason
many americans feel the same cynicism
distrust
and divide
that permeated our politics when i was
younger
[Music]
the leader of the democratic party with
the same fresh sense of optimism and
belief in our values that our party
stands for the same as my digital early
years
because of those divided times that time
in our history
each of these progressives
civil rights women's rights lgbtq plus
rights voting rights fair housing rights
justice were all propelled forward
people rose up they took to the streets
they petitioned their elected leaders
and they demanded reforms that changed
the courts of history
and now my friends
this
is our moment
we
we collectively as democrats are poised
to seize the torch
that has been passed to us in that
turbulent time and those movements but
movements were mostly led by workers
and those movements moved us closer
to the more perfect union
first idolized by our region's founders
so yes
i am very very optimistic about the
future of the new york state democratic
party
and i believe to my core
that this party can and should be a
powerhouse
not to serve one another
but to serve all
so as governor and as the leader of this
party i'm declaring that a whole new day
is gone
one that
[Applause]
and we reject is playbook
that enables
you to succeed on others we're left
behind
and our party must be driven by the same
grit the same perseverance and the
passion to do good
that is
so
let us rebuild this organization
as a beginning of ideas and inclusion
and invincibility rooted
the democratic values are new york
values
and while we believe that there are
those
who are vulnerable there are those who
actually believe that the democrats are
vulnerable this november
i gladly reject that notion right here
and now i reject that notion
because
when we talk to the voters
and should be places of hope
an endless opportunity they will vote
for democrats because we stand together
we are unstoppable
so
why am i so confident
it is still
in one piece of fact
that workers always rise up in the face
of adversity we always rise up
and it just in the last few years
and what we've entered we'll count the
rise in life
we have about the most difficult
times and i know many are still longing
for that sense of normalcy and are
really from persistent sense of loss
loss of loved ones
loss of their livelihoods
and for many
loss of hope
i saw it in the eyes of exhausted nurses
everywhere from buffalo that they did in
the platform he called them heroes
yet they still feel that they're getting
ignored
i saw the eyes of a mother and sounding
[Music]
small is under the bronx
but he was worried
that his little business of hardcore we
fall victim to crime from gun violence
i saw in the eyes of an upstate farmer
who feared that at the heart of the
pandemic
would
actually end his survival
entirely every corner of the state i
heard their stories
and i embrace them as if they're my own
new yorkers lives been turned upside
down are looking to us
their leaders
for results
but we cannot overlook the reality
that the pandemic
racial inequalities and disparities
that's a long time similar to the
service
black mothers in highland and bronze and
merlin
still experience a much higher mortality
rate
white mothers
homeownership or even a formal apartment
is beyond the reach of so many young
people
all they want to do is live in the same
community and grow it
and access the capital and
and we sure know this
women still face barriers to their
success from a lack of child care to
workplaces and tolerate a culture of
harassment these challenges are real
and new yorkers
they need to be open
and honest about how we're going to
solve them
but this much is true
new york's future will not wait
our problems will not fix themselves
meaning this moment must be the common
purpose
[Music]
from generation to generation
and these are the values that will guide
our path forward
grounded in the beliefs of paris and
justice
and equality evidence for all
and that is why we believe that
strong gun safety laws everyone from an
innocent child to our young people to
our police officers are saved from harm
in a true system of justice
to build fantastically law enforcement
in the communities they serve
and mental health resources to help our
neighbors and healthy lives in our home
and not on the streets
from discussing mental health services
for those that are so not calm by this
we also believe in prosperity that
creates a strong middle class
founded in quality education
and workforce training program to lift
people on their pre-ordained destiny
determined by their zip code until now
and we believe
in environmental protection and 100
clean energy future because our
children's children deserve no less
and we believe
we believe
in a respectful organized labor and a
commitment to a future that honors our
heritage
of labor hard-working labor members like
members of my own family
and we believe
the rights
and dignity of every single
lgbtq plus member our family
right for them
and we believe in fairness
for our undocumented workers and
dreamers to give them a peace of mind
and we believe in equality and powers
discrimination sexual harassment or
retaliation and to receive the full
reproductive reproductive freedom that
they deserve that's being denied in
other states
these
these are the core principles
embedded in our dna as new yorkers
today we come together
at a crossroads in new york history
and our country's history
so much of our country heard from
hillary clinton
even part of our state
are so divided people are deeply
retrieving another partisan corners each
team wearing their own colors red and
blue sitting on opposite sides of the
field shouting at each other shouting
over each other
we cannot more than the fact that while
we work for our teams
we
sure on love the sport
despite what's happening in our national
holiday today
we still share a common bond and that is
we are all americans and make no mistake
we are competitive
[Applause]
and that competitive spirit must be
harnessed
and not against other democrats but
against the other side the republicans
so here's my playbook for success
[Applause]
here's my playbook you run with
confidence
about the tenacity of an underdog you
take nothing for granted
and you fight it until the very last
second
and to win we have to demonstrate that
democrats will deliver
over the last six months by working
together
democrats have made europe a better
place to work and to raise a family
we're taking on the tough fights that
matter we're showing it and we listen
first so we act with conviction and
fortitude
and we're restoring faith
in how government works more importantly
who it works for
moving forward
we will not leave anyone behind because
the work cannot succeed unless we all
succeed
[Applause]
our people and in the state for decades
to come
so as we start to write a new chapter
in our state pardon history
our values and priorities must remain as
true as it has
and value of every single human being
it's our party and what defines us is
that we actually
care about people
and we believe that government has a
role to play and create an opportunity
for our people
to ensure that our actions meet the
scope of the challenges we face is it a
show
that the democrats united behind a
comedy can actually do
for
what is the greatest fraction called the
party what is their biggest nightmare
the united democratic party that's what
they're worried about
[Music]
even
we share the same destination
right
we're all democrats
so alongside
the leaders we have and we have
incredible leaders here
the majority leader of the united states
senate chuck schumer
is our leader in washington
on our ticket in november
and you've heard my lieutenant governor
brian benjamin he is a rock star and
he's he's trying to take on
the 370 000 miles you heard about me
traveling he's trying to go for my
record but he's incredible
incredible the passion hardy brings to
this
and talk about passion heart
our attorney general teaches james what
a harsh fighter she is
she is amazing you're so blessed to have
heard not just here new york but as a
national leader in fighting for justice
and fighting against donald trump every
place that appears ugly ahead and she's
not there for us i'm so proud and
who is thomas consummate in public
service who has worked so tirelessly in
the transits and what a great friend and
ally he is and our entire
congressional delegation
[Music]
[Applause]
being at my side for such a long time
and our assembly leaders heard from
crystal people so buffalo zone but also
our state's treasure the jordanian
crystal people's soap and speaker
khaleesi and honorary
we have democrats up and down a ticket
and we will run
as one party and we'll fight every
single vote every single community every
single foreign
[Music]
to destroy what makes new york
well would it make north new york
and this is our best way to stand up
against their cynical and destructive
divers that is to empower and strengthen
our own party
how do we fight against their politics
and vision fear monitoring we organize
we mobilize and we get out the vote very
simple we know how to do this and that's
how we win at one party
one party will continue
and by accepting your nomination
by accepting your nomination i will lead
this party
just by this day
honestly in last step with our values
and as we leave here today my friends
i think of ken roosevelt's words i have
spoken on my very first day office
the story of a man in the arena who is
admired by dust and sweat and blood
and his dark contrast to the tinted
souls who sit on the sidelines
i said for the first time in history
a woman has entered that arena as
daughter
but as i look up
as i look out i see so much more because
i'm not alone
i see
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for this
is our time
and new yorkers will remain in that
sense of pride invisibility unity and of
course
as we enter this arena
i say we rise up
our brothers and sisters we rise up for
our brothers and sisters in labor and
we'll rise up for women and we'll rise
up for working families and we'll rise
up for the lgbtq community we'll rise up
for black brown age and native americans
we'll rise up for new yorkers from
buffalo to brooklyn we'll rise up her
upstate and dante rise up we will rise
up he'll rise up he'll rise up for one
state rise up for one state
yes my friends yes my friend this is a
new day for new york thank you thank you
and may god bless you and god bless
america
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're waiting for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
can i have a motion to adjourn this
convention
so moved by jeffery
second
make sure you turn in your clickers
please we need them for the next time
can i have a second
[Applause]
all those in favor of adjourning this
convention please indicate by saying i
and he opposed
thank you all very much ladies and
gentlemen
conviction is a journey
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
all right